armées de terre de l'air marine ou
encore gendarmerie depuis le début de la
semaine à satory tout le monde marche au
pas les répétitions pour le défilé du
14-juillet s'enchaînent sur le site
militaire yvelinois qui présentent
quasiment les mêmes caractéristiques
techniques que les champs elysées dans
les rangs cette année un régiment
habitués le spy basée à valence et qui
revient tout juste du mali ya toujours
des petites choses qui vont pas sur les
premières répétitions au fur et à mesure
des heures à mesure des entraînements
individuellement que collectivement on
s'améliore pour finalement donner une
impression l'impression d'ensemble qui
soit la plus belle possible silence et
sérieux sont de rigueur lorsque le
général passe les troupes en revue
depuis lundi les 4290 militaire qui
descendront à pied la plus belle avenue
du monde répète cet exercice quatre fois
par jour
malgré cette préparation très minutieuse
le sentiment de fierté l'emportent le
capitaine amélie originaire des yvelines
défilera dimanche avec ses hommes avant
de rejoindre dans quelques jours
l'institut des hautes études de défense
nationale véritable honneur de pouvoir
défiler à la tête donc de certains de
mes personnels on pourrait dire donc de
mon unique
pour terminer un petit peu comme on
dirait avec panache cette ce temps de
commandement
pour certains ce défilé 2018 sera une
première et prendra même des airs de
réunion de famille un père et son fils
tous deux affectés à la base aérienne
107 de vélizy-villacoublay défileront
ensemble le 14 juillet c'est une fierté
de représenter son pays et puis se sont
armés et cioran content d'être là c'est
la deuxième très champs elysées c'est
vraiment un plaisir de défiler avec mon
fils je pense que l'information qu'il a
pu suivre sur la base et apporter le
maximum d'informations je pense qu'ils
se tiennent les défis liés au thème du
défilé cette année fraternité d'armes
sous l'uniforme l'engagement d'une vie
un engagement visible le 14 juillet sur
les champs c'est le fait